to some of the guys who you know maybe
watch
masculinity style content or self-help
style content red pill content whatever
the case may be if you see guys who are
motivated or they are wanting to become
something and become more and
they have ambition
but let's say they they have no idea
where to start like they're a clean
slate
somebody like you who's been through a
lot of different things and seen a lot
of different things
what advice would you give somebody
starting from ground zero because what i
constantly see on my channel
that i've tried to explain to you guys
is like purpose is built you know kind
of brick by brick like the thing that
you do today or the business you maybe
start today or this year this couple
years is probably not the thing you're
going to be doing in 10 to 15 to 20
years
what advice would you give to guys who
say i can't find my purpose i'm sure
you've heard that one before i have no
idea what my purpose is so they just
they sit and they accept that they're
stuck for two three four five years in a
row yeah how old are you again casey 25
yeah so so i mean i've got it like i
definitely agree with you you know it's
built brick by brick and i've got a i've
got a lot of bricks you know i'm close
to 50 and i've seen it done a lot of
stuff so um
it actually brings me to the point of
one of the things that i'm working on
this year i'm i'm actually putting
together a course um i'm gonna call it
the school of entrepreneurship and i'm
gonna break down all of these elements
you know for the mindset so what i'll do
is i'll share some of that with you
right now um
i think if
if you want to start anywhere i mean
like this is where i started anyway so
for those people that
didn't have a entrepreneurial household
uncold father mother you know
grandparents whatever
um
that's totally fine because the world's
knowledge is available to you in books
and podcasts
youtube's a little bit difficult to
filter through because there's a lot of
shells out there that just press upload
and really haven't got a clue what
they're talking about but
um i mean if there's a published book by
an entrepreneur that's successful
you can be damn sure that it's something
worth you know taking a look at so some
of the stuff that i'd recommend you know
consuming to sort of get your head
screwed on right to set the frame for it
would be something like richard
branson's losing my virginity shoe dog
which is a book on nike uh the
everything store which is basically a
biography on uh jeff bezos on amazon um
those would be the big ones to sort of
get the idea of the sort of stuff that
these guys had to do to accomplish what
they accomplished because a lot of
people look at stuff like that and
they're like oh that's an overnight
success and it's like no you don't
understand an overnight success that
that you know that most people look at
that label is an overnight success like
even you are not in your head because
you know because i mean like your grind
was probably one two three years of like
uploads with crickets yeah you finally
got traction right right exactly people
only see you today they only see you on
your channel they only see you on social
media and they're like oh that guy you
know that guy got lucky or he's an
overnight success but they don't see the
grind leading up to it so
a lot of these books have that grind and
i think that you know the grind part of
life is that is probably the main part
that's missing in most men's lives today
is they don't understand what it takes
to achieve success
and they don't often have um you know
the gumption to actually go and do those
things so
i'm going to frame all this thing in
like different learning modules to like
sort of break down all the stuff that i
that i came across personally in a lot
of the stuff that i've seen a lot of the
guys that i've mentored use yeah um but
that's probably the best starting place
is to consume
uh biographies on the most success i
mean if you admire somebody else like um
you know for example if you're a
basketball fan a great book to consume
actually two of them would be uh tim s
grover who's the author who was also the
trainer for michael jordan
okay um and he wrote one i think around
2011 called relentless and then the
follow-up to that was called winning and
i think that was at about a year or two
ago i've listened to them both on
audible the great books but when you
listen to them and i don't even like
basketball but when you listen to them i
mean you really understand
what it was that he and jordan did and
how they collaborated how they worked
together to have been as successful as
they were right there's a lot of work
that goes into success right people just
see the results they don't see the blood
sweat and tears right
so you left corporate america you said
in 2003 correct correct so since then i
mean if you're looking at like 19 years
how many
how many industries have you
pivoted into or businesses have you sold
or different endeavors that's molded you
into an entrepreneur
okay so i've done um i've been involved
in credit card debt relief which is one
of my more success actually definitely
the most uh successful business uh in
corporate world with employees
i had a lead generation business uh
which didn't work out that one folded
within about a year and a half
um i had a few other uh physical
products that were just they just never
went anywhere um i had a bad team
um got involved in a indoor go-kart
track which went absolutely nowhere
um
what else did i do youtube obviously you
know which you can find out about i've
published books um
those would be the main ones that i can
think of i've also got a supplement line
right now
uh i'm working on another physical
product which is um which i'm
collaborating with some guys in my
community so i'm just i'm just basically
doing as as much as i can with the time
that i have and then there's of course a
passive stuff that i've built over the
last 10 years as well which
um you know lets me take these risks and
these stabs so i can diversify in other
things so i've got passive income
sitting in digital currency and real
estate and investments and you know like
other businesses that i've also invested
in that i'm not directly involved in but
i also get paid monthly dues on it as
well too so there's so there's different
places that you want to go once you once
you've got that got that one success you
know the knock it out of park i mean i
was lucky enough to have a good
accountant that was like okay look you
know you've created this goose that lays
a golden egg now every single month
right and you're very strong with cash
flow and we need to diversify we need to
create a hold co we need to put some
protective measures in place we need to
get this in some real estate and to an
insurance like all these different
things that we ended up doing
um i did that about 12 15 years ago so
it's you know it was all it was all part
and parcel of good planning and making
sure that i found the right people to
come on the ride with me yeah so with
that like there's there's two points i
want to make so the first point i want
to make is obviously to the people
watching this or to the guys who are
watching this one thing that stands out
to me instantly is like
your failed endeavor like you had
successes in business and then you had
failed endeavors that you're totally
upfront with
but the thing that i noticed is like a
lot of guys what happens is they hit
their first train run of failure and
they automatically assume that they're a
failure or they don't keep going so like
i think the point to hammer home with
that is like obviously like your
evolution in business
it's full-on continuing and the second
like you just stop at complacency or
something like that like that's what i
see a lot of guys doing is they try one
thing or they they get enough courage to
attempt something and then because that
one thing didn't work out they
oftentimes just go nowhere you know what
i mean do you see that too with some of
the guys you've mentored yeah you're
either growing or dying you can't stay
still like that's just the natural state
of nature i mean if you look at a tree i
mean it's either growing or it's dying
right like it never comes back in the
spring the leaves never come back sort
of thing so
you know like as a as a living being
here on this earth i mean we have we
only have so much time let's just set
aside whatever happens you know when
that time ends but
during that time that you're walking
you're either growing or dying so you
have to intentionally you know walk
through life in such a way that you know
you make decisions that are aligned with
the sort of life that you want right
like you paint this picture of the sort
of life that you want to create and
every single day you do something that
gets you closer to that or if you find
yourself doing things that aren't aren't
aligned with that because you've painted
that picture and you've got clarity then
that's when you're like okay i need to
stop doing this this isn't a good use of
my time it's not aligned with where i
want to go
a lot of people um you know to your
point they
you know when they reach a
obstacle then they usually just stop
i don't agree with everything that ryan
holiday has written about i'm not a fan
of his ego as the enemy book but i think
his book the obstacles away is a
fantastic book it's one that i recommend
because quite often an obstacle can
become the way um so i'll give an
example like um
there was uh legislation that was
introduced to
ontario parliament here where i live in
2010 or 11 which would essentially have
um put my debt business um basically out
of business um it would have delayed the
first revenue event by about eight
months and cut the amount that we would
have been paid by to about one-third
right so that so that's crippling like
that's a extinction level event that's
like a meteor hitting the earth and just
you know most of society stops so
um we had to figure out how to deal with
that because that was a serious and
critical problem right we had 23 staff
we were doing close to 300 000 a month
at that time in uh sales revenue
and we had a lot of customers we had a
lot of responsibilities i had
obligations to staff and and vendors and
rent and on all these other future
payments that were due
so um you know through some hard work
and some gumption we found a way to make
it work and you know long story short
most of the businesses that were in the
industry folded or left canada and we
were i think the only one that survived
if i'm not mistaken most of them that
did try to push through
the deadline date where the legislation
changed the law either flopped within
about six to twelve months or they just
packed it in you know fairly shortly but
um i think it's been about seven seven
years now past the uh
legislative changes that the company's
still been around
oh wow
cool
so when when guys
when guys get into certain industries or
when guys you know break through in a
certain market or like the another thing
too i see with entrepreneurs is like
they have a hard time seeing the vision
of what could actually come with the
fruits of their labor in either one year
down the road from where they're at
right now or two years down the road
and maybe they're operating like they're
they're working a lot or they're
operating at break even or just slightly
above break even
a guy like you who's been through
different industries and you've seen
different things whether that be with
like legislation like you just said or
you know selling businesses or trying
different endeavors
when do you personally believe is the
right time to pivot
right and and swap industries like that
or realize like because i i think
entrepreneurs in general i know i dealt
with this too like especially with with
youtube before i pivoted a little bit
with how i was speaking and the types of
videos i was doing i think entrepreneurs
in general can be stubborn
right so if you do have any ego involved
with it with the you know sometimes it's
like the market that you're in how do
you personally know when to pivot and
when to make those pivots versus
sticking things out if you're
potentially close to a breakthrough
yeah i think that humans in general are
stubborn when they're sort of set in
their ways and
one of the key traits of
every successful entrepreneur that i've
met and i've i've known a lot i mean
i've been involved in um entrepreneurs
work tractor in toronto for a number of
years i've done other uh groups of
mastermind groups so i've met quite a
lot of these guys and
the one common theme story is you have
to know when to pivot and the answer the
question you know
how do you know when to it's really as
soon as you realize that you have to do
it right um
you know like a great story that i love
and you know like i only knew this story
simply because i spent so much time
consuming content listening to podcasts
and like you know basically
watching what those that are chasing
excellence do and then mimicking that
you know r d doesn't stand for research
and development to me it stands for rip
off and duplicate yeah so i mean if you
look at a great story something like
netflix like netflix put blockbuster out
of business because they were delivering
dvds in the mail they had lower cost of
overhead and their system was
pretty much superior right
it had flaws but it was but it was a
better system so what happened
blockbuster you know literally the
biggest um you know movie rental
business at the time had to fold and
close their doors and shut down all
their retail operations well now
blockbuster sorry not blocks but now
netflix had a new problem because we had
the age of um faster internet more
people had internet connections we had
consoles with apps we had uh tablets and
screens and people were starting to
stream content on devices so rather than
continue to ship dvds to and from people
in the mail they're like all right let's
set up a
streaming service and let's pivot yeah
um you know there's a great story you
know behind
instagram as well pretty much every
every successful business out there has
a pivot story and in some cases it's not
just one major pivot it can be several
got you
you